he got too horny that's what he says
[Music]
anybody here a Seth Rogen fan I am not
I'm a traveler I'm a big Jabbawockeez
fan I like his movies
I used to be a Seth Rogen I don't really
care about him as a person I did I I was
like turned off by what he said about
[ __ ] L.A the casing what do you say
about L.A when like when people were
talking about how they get like their
cars robbed and all this [ __ ] and he was
like well that's La what do you expect
or some [ __ ] like that that was that was
kind of weird did he say that did I
misqually no you're right something like
that that was a sentiment yeah it was
[ __ ] dumb I'm like are you kidding
you should just be apathetic like okay
your movies suck now yeah yeah dude I
hated this no I don't get any of your
jokes I hate your laugh well
um two people recently I'll just cut to
it since that was that was a downer uh
two people recently dude you know what
did he do [ __ ] cure ovarian cancer
again no no he he made he made pots
huh he like does pottery and [ __ ] I
don't give up about him and his pots and
[ __ ] I'm in the clay I do clay things
what is this article from two people
weekly paid forty thousand dollars each
to smoke weed with Seth Rogen and learn
Pottery for him okay so he needs money
great I hope his [ __ ] car gets broken
into while he's doing that [ __ ] it's a
centrelationship steal his spare clay
that's so funny I didn't realize how
much you don't like Seth Rogen that's
really funny I just
I it sucks because I loved him that's
why I feel betrayed him because I loved
Seth Rogen I watched all and you love LA
and you love college native and then I'm
native LA and then he said that [ __ ] and
I was like dude that is so [ __ ] whack
I think that's how I feel about Will
Smith I loved him and I'm like why did
you behave like that young man
yeah that's how I get around that I just
blame Jada I just blame her that's what
I do I blame Jada for [ __ ] Seth Rogen
too
but uh so he paid someone paid him
twenty thousand dollars each okay forty
thousand dollars each is it for charity
it is he doesn't give a [ __ ] about 40
Grand right he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
40. he does give a [ __ ] about smoking
weed and [ __ ] Pottery though if I had
the Moolah I would pay that to hang out
with Dave Chappelle for like a week oh
yeah absolutely yeah so let's get into
our scenarios because nobody gives a
[ __ ] about Seth broken but I'd be super
down to smoke weed hang out with Dave
and really get to know him that seems
really fun for 40 Grand yeah a week oh
yeah right are you out of your [ __ ]
mind one smoke session and pottery
you're saying [ __ ] what are you gonna
live with them for a week I'm trying to
get a deal Bart wants a [ __ ] week at
Dave Chappelle's life how about five
business days would you take would you
accept money if a fan wanted to hang out
with you for a week 40 G's [ __ ] yeah
yeah what would you do I'd [ __ ] get
my likeness so they could bang my mouth
you did say and that's only five grand a
month that's a call back
five G's a month
but that's stupid they're not banging
your actual face yeah
dude okay all right let's say we all had
we all had a JK charity and obviously
it's for a great cause but we're not
gonna worry about the cause yeah what
would you auction off and what do you
think is the price you would receive for
it oh auction off from my experience
truly like like what do you actually
have to offer a fan okay you know what
I'm saying like I'm assuming maybe a fan
might maybe want to like work out with
you or like get private coaching and or
I don't know you know what I mean like
what what do you have to offer and then
what do you think you're gonna get for I
have no idea what I have to offer that
that's that's pleasurable to them how
about you pick what he would offer yeah
yeah yeah look at this what because
they're gonna [ __ ] pay 40 G's to
[ __ ] fall asleep with me at 9pm
dude that's a great that's a great thing
though how to fall asleep before the
Moon shows itself
seven up masterclass my life's boring as
[ __ ] dude
I would I would okay this is uh yeah a
fan of Bart as a fan of bar this is what
I would want to do for one day let's be
reasonable okay one day that sounds I
don't know how much I paid for this full
24 hours or like a 12 hour day I don't
know we we know it's gonna we know it's
a [ __ ] 12-hour day dude you're gonna
fall asleep at 8 45. let's do a tight
12. I probably want to I probably do
want to work out with you if I'm a fan
of Bart okay okay I probably would enjoy
maybe shooting some of your guns oh
that's cool
that's a good hand yeah
um I would hope that you would sweeten
the deal and maybe like take me to like
a fight or something
sure
I'm down with that okay I thought we
were talking about a restaurant okay
and then after that
um after that you [ __ ] barbecue some
meat for me
that's actually that sounds pretty fun
yeah okay you don't get to eat some guns
go to a fight and then he's barbecuing
meat that he bought this pre-cooked from
Costco yeah that's fine that's a little
rotisserie chicken he makes it more well
done that's why there's 20 chickens I
make hey that's already cooked oh damn
that would be my as a fan of barnacuan
that's what I would want on the table
okay and then from there it's an auction
yeah you know so you let the fan decide
that's pretty cool you maybe agree to
the terms for Nick I would I would pay
money I actually would do this to sit in
traffic with Nick
I'm actually just gonna sit back unless
dude honestly I'm I don't even get mad
anymore when I drive I don't believe you
oh [ __ ] dude you're like blushing right
now tomorrow tomorrow when we all go uh
to our adventure night okay I'll ride
with you let's go all right everybody in
Nick's car you'll see how [ __ ] chill
I am how about this
let's drive far tomorrow let's do go on
Colorado Boulevard
the minute you roll into Colorado
Boulevard
we every single stop we introduce two or
three more student drivers the car with
the double steering wheel and the the
teachers are all sleeping dude I might I
might commit a homicide so the drivers
just do whatever the [ __ ] they want they
break check you they don't even know
what's going on they're not using their
blanket and then they see how you well
plus it's legal to jaywalk now so
everybody's jaywalking in front of you
that's what we're going to do yeah
you're the only one that gets pulled
over
that seems like my life dude I would I
would want to pay for that at the
auction yeah I'll probably [ __ ] flip
a wig dude I'll [ __ ] flip out dad I
want you to introduce me to a couple of
your uh homeless neighbors unhoused
neighbors we could do that we could do
that and we could probably sell that for
15 bucks and I want you to take me to
Target and we have to steal something I
did that the other day oh geez I stole
these pants from Target the other day
you didn't know and we have to sit down
to dinner with your family you don't
want to do that and you gotta [ __ ]
share your cold ass watermelon
oh that's good watermelon there we
[ __ ] yeah yeah I get a couple
watermelon I picked the Watermelons out
for everybody dude and then don't don't
get it we're gonna go we're gonna go to
no no please let me tell you we're gonna
go to YouTube studio and then we have to
fight but you have to let me win which
shouldn't be too difficult right yeah I
would pay to hang out with you and when
you go to teach your [ __ ] workshops
in all these different countries I'm
picking the song man
so we have to go International together
oh damn how do you choreography that
[ __ ] and you better kill it yeah you
better kill it you know or they won't
happen back in Croatia smash them dude I
would take a day with Ryan he just
teaches me how to play music I would
rather shoot myself and we go find bum
[ __ ] I wouldn't take a day with Ryan and
and he would take me to a cemetery
he'd tell me about all the stories of
like you know
Cemetery it's like what are we doing in
a military cemetery and then I sit and
then there's tears at every one of them
tears with a personal story Jesus that
would take all day 12 hours I know I
thought you just wanted 12 hours man and
then Steve is just he just shows me how
to get rich dude and then get wrecked
yeah I'm gonna go shopping with Steve
yeah I got you wardrobe I also want
Steve to write a movie script for me oh
that's a good prize like hey you're good
at this in a way where where you are the
hero or in a way where in a day by the
way everyone laughs at your ass do you
can write a movie in day probably could
yeah see can't write a movie today it's
a rough draft though it's Ultra rough no
it's got to go it's got to go to print
right now it's pretty good though that
is that is legit the one thing I
actually would cover from Steve for real
like I'll be like dude 60 Pages that's
the one thing do I have any other value
okay I would have Colleen feel me just
doing absolute nothing I'd rather kill
myself have you seen like she could
shoot such amazingly beautiful shots and
I'll just be like just me going
wait that's actually a great idea one of
my favorite videos that you have on
Instagram is you with a little tiny uh
cardboard and you doing like break
dancing moves on yeah teach me how to do
that I would love for her to reshoot
that with epic music you have to score
it afterwards you were saying she has to
slow-mo your pain after you [ __ ]
scrape your hip and [ __ ] zoom in on my
skin that's now on the pavement yeah
yeah that's what I want you know that
where Joe has to soundtrack deal with
this [ __ ] oh that's a Saved by the
Bell music what does Joe do what's Joe's
Joe shows me what porn he's beating off
to and he beats off to it in the room
he's like
no I paid you for this could you grab a
towel on your way out
dab that's a funny thing prove that you
really like this weird [ __ ] Joe's Joe's
he has to take me to like uh a
whorehouse and then he has to he has to
eat out the [ __ ]
yes dude
we still need his complete story about
that by the way yeah me too I thought it
was very a short story
yeah Joe's story was like he paid to eat
a hooker yeah okay he goes I was just
really horny I don't know what overcame
him and that's what he wanted to do he
got too horny that's what he says and
then he forgot that there's been a lot
of stuff going on down there before this
was an easy day at work yeah exactly
geez man that's crazy what a gentleman
huh I know what a good guy what a good
guy that shows who you really are does
that make Joe a good guy I think so yeah
yeah at the end of the day that shows
what you really comment below if you
think that makes jokes
describe your character hashtag Joe's a
good guy hit the Bell if you think Joe's
a good guy
[Music]
[Music]